hey everyone diolo here and today we are
back for the fifth part of hio iraqi's
beautifully crafted world of steelball
run following the Mind melting battle
that Al just had against the boom boom
family and Mountain T small engagement
against them as well wyom means only if
anime character continue session
tracking down the supposed murderer
however along the way and as everyone
pushes further into the desert they
begin to discover some unknown secrets
that change the entire Outlook they
currently have on life what are these
mysterious Powers the boom boom family
members had where is gyro from and how
is someone able to activate the spin all
of that and more is somewhat answered in
this extremely underrated section of
Steel ball run the devil's Palm
[Applause]
[Music]
Ark kicking things right back off
somehow the boom poom family has managed
to flee from any sight of battle and now
our main boys Johnny and Gyro are being
chased down by Mountain Tim they don't
know who it currently is though and in
all honesty they're at their wit's end
as they've kept up the same pace for
around 3 hours now pulling at his
telescope Johnny notes how it doesn't
seem like a member of the boom boom
family the dude's riding skills have
increased plus he never saw a member in
that weird ass hat Jo knows that if they
slow down though and let him get close
then the magnetism will start again what
they need to do is to get to the
watering hle first otherwise this will
all be one big mess with only 15 km to
go now both Johnny and jaro push forth
trying to make a break for it but after
looking back and seeing that the dude's
even closer jar points out that he knows
the guy he isn't one of the boom boom
family members so it just leaves him
confused as to why he's tracking them
down like this now Janny asks what their
next plan of action is but J tells him
that they have to lose him there is no
other option they can't let anybody get
close to them in this desert stage plus
nobody following them at night time
would be doing so without a mentally
deranged reason over with him as he
kicks up dust and gains more and more
speed he knows that the murderer of
three participants is no one other than
Johnny joar it's hard to believe as he
never suspected such a person to act
like this but the prince lead to him
either way it's certain that he used his
curse ability for those murders and Tim
will arrest him dead or alive to put an
end to the unnecessary Bloodshed taking
another glance over at Mountain Tim gyro
is just confused with how he's climbing
uphill but still gaining speed realizing
what's up though Johnny points out that
the setu isn't originally what they
thought instead of just accelerating
it's different but they never noticed
Jud to themselves also running what's
actually happening is that Johnny is
also being pulled towards him from
behind suddenly all of the bolts in Iron
attachments on Johnny saddle detaches
and begins pulling him backwards with
even more Force J calls out for his boy
but in that instant he too is randomly
hit by all of his horses iron
attachments and forced up into the air
watching from nearby the boom boom
family gloats over how their plan is all
coming together they knew Mountain had
the speed to catch up and enter the Jo's
magnetic circle now all that they need
is for the three of them to clash
together wanting to get in closer La
asks if they can get him close enough to
watch them all explode and their father
agrees however Andre who's still in pain
over having a hole freaking blowing in
his stomach starts noting that
everything's blurring and he feels
chills going down his spine Ben though
it's just like chill son now it's not
the time this is far more important also
I completely forgot but I Liv out so
much wackiness from this family
throughout the last video they are all
mentally insane it was just impossibly
hard to weave it into the story as they
attacked our group but anyways anyways
confused over how in the world his body
is also magnetized as well Joe asks if
Johnny ever touched anything or touched
as that would make sense here thinking
for a moment Johnny theorizes that it
could have possibly been the bullet shot
earlier and something might have
attached itself then with Tim getting
closer now it causes Johnny to start
getting pulled along the desert floor
with him unable to stop himself J
screams out for him but in that same
instant his magnetization activates and
he also starts getting dragged back
knowing for a fact now that it's
Mountain Tim who they're being dragged
towards Johnny screams that the bone
boom family must have touched him as
well at some point because it's all
three of them that are being pulled
towards each other now back when they
first noticed the effects again it was
too weak for them to fully realize what
was actually going on but now as the
three of them get closer to each other
the magnetic strength grows and
multiplies Jo questions why like Tim
obviously hasn't fallen as well but
Johnny points out that he hasn't even
realized what's going on since he's
still running forwards screaming out in
pain Johnny notes that the iron in his
blood is beginning to collect together
and that if all three of them do Collide
it'll most likely result in an explosion
to fix all of it he states that they
need to get his attention now and urge
him to get off the horse getting closer
M notices that the two guys he was
tracking now are randomly on the ground
and can even hear them yelling something
but due to the dust around our Joo it's
making it impossible for him to hear
what they're trying to say figuring that
like even if he could hear them he most
likely wouldn't stop go decides that
it's best to drag him off his horse
himself pulling at a steel ball Jo
throws it up into the sky towards the
quickly approaching Mountain Tim
watching it fly off Johnny doesn't think
it'll reach and instead just get ripped
back due to the
magnetization however and always like
big braining every single situation
jarro had pre-priced this and states
that of course it will return because of
the magnetic force but if it does return
the force in his eyes should be enough
to knock him off his horse all of a
sudden the steel ball slams into the
side of a rock formation before as
previously predicted shooting back
towards gyro due to the magnetic force
revealing his true plan gyro points out
that he scattered some dust from those
rocks and inside of those rocks are iron
scraps he urges Johnny to brace as since
all of them are currently magnets this
is going to hurt like hell looking up at
the Rock full above him mounted Tim all
of a sudden assaulted by a flurry of
tiny iron shards that attract to his
exact location back over with the boys
the exact same thing is obviously
happening with them however due to
Mountain Tim not suspecting in the
attack and knocked him back off his
horse subsequently bringing everyone to
a pause finally realizing that a random
force is pulling him and then instead of
falling he's actually being dragged
through the sky with his own pistol
slowly starting to merge into him Johnny
screams that it's useless everyone's
already too close and Mountain T's body
is uncontrollably flying through the air
now noting that the force of the magnets
has become overwhelming Johnny screams
that his veins are about to burst
however just before all three of them
exploded Mount T used its trusty rope to
tie himself to the top of a rock then
merged each piece of his body into the
Rope so that he could transport himself
to
safety safely out of the dangerous
magnetic zone now Tim guesses that if
all three of them get too close then
something not so pretty might happen
here figuring that he totally
misunderstood the Joo that he was
tracking he asked Johnny who this
magnetic force belongs to and to explain
in detail what exactly has been going on
nearby looking through some binoculars
and realizing that all three of them
didn't explode been complains that they
need to cut that damn rope otherwise all
three of them could get away back over
with uh the trio now hearing about the
boom boom family's ability to control
iron and realizing that all along the
family was the real culprit Mountain Tim
tells the guys that they should get
further away to losing the hold curious
over what the hell is going on with Tim
though Jo asks if he's even human
wondering what the steel balls are
himself Tim just asks jar to explain his
first jar states that it's just a part
of his technique and that there are
still parts of the human being that are
a great mystery knowing something about
these Mysteries of the human body Tim
goes on to say that 15 years earlier
when he was 16 he was a part of the army
and was assigned to venture out into the
unmapped parts of the Arizona desert
sadly the unit got lost and all 16 of
them wandered the desert for days
searching for any signs of life in water
having heard of the story before Johnny
asks if he was a part of their lost
Cavalry units according to Tim the area
that he got lost in was a spot the local
Indian feared and called The Devil's
Palm the unit's compasses were useless
and the ground was constantly moving due
to quick sand mountains would come and
go Canyons would form and the landscape
would forever change itself the Indians
say that the devil's Palm travels many
miles in a day where it could be found a
month ago it would be lost the next
according to Indian tradition a shooting
star crashed there long ago destroying
absolutely everything now it's cursed
nobody knows how large the area is and
nobody knows its location until they
happen to see it themselves apparently
it's been traveling this area for tens
of thousands of years after a while of
failing to find water the horses and
Tim's group sadly died then those from
the unit fell one by one even Tim was on
the verge of being fried to death by the
sun however that place was also a land
that carried Destinies for an unknowing
reason Tim awoke half dead during the
night randomly a tiny bit of water had
gathered on the rope and his body was
now absorbed it on its own in that
moment his body became one with the rope
and because of that he was the only
Survivor thinking on that moment for all
of these years Tim poses that it could
have been a sort of gravitation through
that gravitation the devil's Palm has
awoken the power to use hidden abilities
inside of his body according to him the
Indians call it a cursed ability and
perhaps it is cursed due to how it was
only Tim who survived after the entire
unit died however he personally calls
his ability a stand and his eyes there
is no mistake at all the boom boom
family must have also stepped into the
devil's Palm to awaken a stand jar
points out that the magnetic force is
getting weaker and weaker so he urges
Tim to keep moving further away with his
robe still gring his teeth he knows that
the only way they can continue though is
if they actually tracked down and beat
the hell out of that stupid ass family
suddenly appearing behind him though la
boom states that there is no need for
that at all taking all three of the guys
by complete surprise bending down la
then proceeds to make some sort of like
marking on the ground while at the same
time her dad Dismounts his horse and
begins to approach them La proudly
gloats that there ain't no need for them
to find distance anymore as the only
Direction the trio can travel now is
closer to each other speaking up Ben
asks his daughter if she needs a hand
with cutting Tim's rope but she just
states that she's not feeling so
confident right now attempting to get
the upper hand J tosses his steel ball
directly at La however as she places her
hand on the marking she made on the
floor a iron sand suddenly shoots its
way forth or simultaneously that same
lizard stand creature appears on top of
Gyro having stopped the steel balls
rotation the salamander looking stand
slams both Johnny and jaro together
leaving them with nowhere to go before
darting up the cliff side towards Tim
using his rope ability Tim detaches his
forearm then uses the revolver that was
stuck there to shoot all of its bullets
towards La who was unprotected below
sadly for him Ben quickly jumps in and
has his stand up here to block the
bullet in time allowing the other one to
fully get a hold of mountain Tim
following her dad's orders and binding
everyone's hands so they can't retaliate
now she then follows up and cuts the
Rope holding Tim to the Rock seeing this
Johnny screams out that they're screwed
now while up in front Tim reacts to just
how heavy he currently is with nowhere
to go the two boom boom family members
Glo that it doesn't matter what they do
now it's useless inside of this boundary
bending over and wondering if he has a
hand free Joe tells Johnny to do it if
he has a handfree he just has the the
spin he points out that like right
beside him is a bullet it's one of
mountain Tims that he shot earlier so
it's made of lid and won't be influenced
by the magnetic force and all he needs
to do now is to make it spin looking up
and seeing Mountain Tim seconds from
colliding Johnny just thinks that it's
all too late now slamming into each
other all three of the guys scream out
in pain as their bodies are constantly
pulled towards each other jaru tries to
get Johnny to remember lesson three and
how when they were camped out he did
manage to spin the cork the idea is the
same now he just has to do it with a
bullet Johnny screams that surely that
was only a coincidence but JY urges him
to believe in the spin the power of
rotation is Limitless and he just needs
to trust him on that screaming that he
must do it Johnny has to save them
Johnny himself places the bullet between
his index finger and thumb and wonders
if he can really do it he's only done it
once before he can't forget though this
is it this is why he signed up for the
race to find out the secret of the spin
and learn it for himself so in that case
he will do it otherwise everything will
end here and just as gyu screams that
his body is beginning to burst Johnny
flexs his thumb forth and in that moment
of pure astonishment watches the bullet
spin freely inside of his hand yelling
to his boy that he's managed to do it he
spun the bullets all signs of winning
the battle are suddenly ended when Ben
Stomps down on his arm causing him to
drop the bullets knowing the gravity of
how dangerous these people are Ben tells
his daughter to step back and be on
guard until all of this is over as the
dying often make some desperate final
moves crying in pain now Johnny can't
believe that he failed and tells jar
that he just couldn't do it randomly
Ellie begins freaking the hell out
though almost crying she tells her dad
that he told her to be careful but now
she wants him to just come back cuz of
that that that damn hand she pleads with
him to leave however as the confused man
looks down to see what the hell she's
talking about Johnny notices some
circular pedants emanating out from
below his hand the guys all look at him
wondering what the hell's going on and
in that moment Johnny flicks his hand
over to see what it could possibly be
all of a sudden and looking at the nails
dancing to top the tip of his fingers
Johnny freaks the hell out wondering
what in the world his fingernails are
doing why are they spinning Tim wonders
if it could possibly be a stand and
jarro notes that for sure it isn't the
same as when he uses his steel balls
over with LA and screaming for her
father to come back now she points out
that something's wrong with his leg
looking down a random part of the earth
is then cut open and Ben's leg is
suddenly 7 and2 absolutely confused
himself Johnny looks at his fingernails
spinning at an even faster rate now
before touching the ground again and
seeing a massive slash that completely
slices the eldest boom boom family
member in
half well it looks like our boy Johnny
has a stand now but it's not time to
fully reveal the eye-catch video there
subscribe if you guys have enjoyed the
video plus smash that like button and
help try push this one past 1,000 likes
again I want to shout out to all the
amazing people and S of the JoJo's
Community it's been an absolute blast
watching all of these stand eye catches
and just the videos you guys have
created over time and implementing them
into my video along with the almost
infinite amount of Music provided by
some of the most talented artists out
there it's it's just been amazing the
series truly deserves the best adaption
doesn't matter if it's early on in the
buildup it all needs to be crafted in
the way I hope the community will
thoroughly enjoy and that we can look
back on before part even does finally
get its own anime whenever that might be
cuz it's still not confirmed sadly still
fix seen my gyro gyro issues but hey you
know I'm pretty much there now either
way I I think this was fantastic we
finally got a glimpse here of Johnny's
ability at the end but we also saw our
first of the series antagonists like
proper antagonists I don't really say
that about uh Mrs Robinson from the last
video because their eye ability I don't
know I I feel like they weren't really
any major threat or anything like that
some IMD Southern American Vibes coming
off these ones for sure though somehow
they also randomly stumbled upon the pal
at some point and ended up gaining a
stand like how how did that even how do
these absolute idiots manage to get a
stand survive the desert and make it out
it's just still I I honestly can't wait
to get into the next part of the series
where we start to uncover a lot more
about who exactly jar zelli is and his
reasonings for joining the race to begin
with we know Johnny's here because of
Gyro and his steel balls but why is gyro
here so find out next time for now it's
been your professional degenerate Deo
and I'll see you all and a BS bye